[Music]  the presidential election getting very  close only two weeks away the race is  virtually tied  now experts are saying the election may  be decided by one or two key swing  states including as usual the state of  florida florida may decide  if yet another presidential election is  decided by the voters in florida  i just want to make a quick plea to  florida citizens to take their  responsibility seriously  and get out there and vote  florida we know you're watching  this is for you  the future of this great nation  may rest in one state  florida it might be you  can we trust you to make a stand  you're a state full of great people  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  there's a lot to win or lose  [Music]  [Music]  of america  [Music]  oh  [Applause]